this is the bismillah alhamdulillah
peace be with you you're watching the D
show AMA D your host and my next guest
you might know him you already known
from a vast topic that we did and we
condensed it into the top 10 reasons why
Jesus the Christ the Messiah peace be
upon him who is beloved to our hearts we
believe he was a Muslim and he did Islam
because Islam means to surrender and
submit to the one God and Jesus pray to
the one God he worshiped the one God and
he was a Muslim because a Muslim is one
who does Islam does all these acts of
worship and we did the top ten reasons
why this mighty messenger Jesus peace be
upon him is beloved to our hearts and we
proved that in no way did he ever call
people to worship Him that he was not
God never claimed to be God and has
stirred up a lot of emotions but when
the motion settles the light bulb went
on and people were excited because they
got to see through all the confusion and
that's my next guest was coming out
Joshua Evans we're gonna be talking more
about this here on the D so sit tight
don't go nowhere
this is the thing
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam muhammad
Allah must be with you he's be with you
brother how you been how you been I've
been good at him that he love praise be
to God and I've been very very good how
have you been I've been all good thanks
to God to the credit heavens and earth
it's been a long time since you've been
with us how's everything been
everything's been good it has been a
long time
we've both been hard at work doing the
Dagwood spreading the message of light I
had a lot there's only one God worthy of
worship and that is the one true created
the heavens the earth so it's always
been good now you heard me open the show
top ten reasons why Jesus peace be upon
him who we loved dearly he never claimed
to be God wasn't God and we covered this
together in the top ten reasons why he
wasn't God we proved that intellectually
academically and you had that wonderful
list how was the response that you got I
had so many people writing in they were
amazed you know when the motions or some
people a little emotional when that calm
down light go went on many people were
accepting Islam the way that Jesus lives
submission to the one guy what kind of
response were you again because you were
touring the world doing this topic the
response was as you said in the
beginning a lot of people because it has
this shock value you know so a lot of
emotions do get stirred up but when you
let people calm down to say little
issues rationally look at the
information you know and then it's on
you to decide for yourself we're not
forcing anybody you know we are just
giving them and disseminating
information so when we gave them the
clear information with the evidences it
was up to them and then we all I started
to see the response come in and we did
have a lot of people accept Islam based
on this information I'll handle that
praise be to the one creator did you
ever get any people say you know what
you weren't Christian enough you never
were Christian that's why I've had
plenty of that response that I never was
a true Christian yeah or that I never
was a Christian at all period that it
was a false claim or you never had like
the Holy Ghost in yourself for sure how
did you answer this well I answered this
by first and foremost just stating that
that that's kind
an emotional response to tell me what I
was and was not you know based on how I
am now to tell me I wasn't this at one
point in my life
realistically that's between me and my
Creator I know that at one point in my
life I truly did believe Jesus was gone
I truly believe that God was a man and
that man and and that Jesus was God and
man that God was one in three at all
this this is something I truly believed
as an ideology you know but when the
information came out and I studied the
information from a unbiased perspective
the information that I gave to our
viewers was the information I received
myself and accepted it in Internet to
Islam this is amazing it's amazing tell
us also now before you even get to this
step because we cater to a lot of people
out of people tune in all praises to the
creator of the heavens in the earth that
now he's given us this platform we have
a not a lot of not yet Muslims and a lot
of them you know you have to like kind
of take a leap and come to to be able to
sit through a lot of these shows because
you know what a lot of people are
indulging in you know the action movies
and and and and although the
entertainment out there so maybe some of
some or someone you know who's got their
friend they're not yet Muslim friend and
this guy just came from the nightclub
now you talking about Jesus and all
these other you know important topics
purpose of life but why is this for that
person that's kind of struggling to sit
through this we've got to be sitting
through this why is this topic because
even the Christians and other people of
other phase they know that this is a
serious topic and they should listen all
right to get a different perspective
what about also those other that we
can't cater to the people kind of like
more maybe you call the hedonist people
are just pleasure seekers nightclubs
boys girls you know young young young
ones at 14 15 who are just thinking
about that lifestyle but now they're
finally watching a Dean show and they're
hearing you talking about this mighty
messenger Jesus and we're gonna go into
it as vast topics why is this such an
important topic they should be excited
to listen about well it's such an
important topic because I believe it is
also a stepping stone topic because
Jesus is one of the most famous if not
the most famous figure in history and a
lot of things have been said about him
and a lot of ideologies the major world
religion has a major world religion
Christianity has been formulated around
the personage of Jesus so it it is just
you know according to
pure logic that we need to sit down and
say okay who was Jesus really there are
so many things said about him
there's so many even within Christianity
there are so many different ideologies
about Christ himself and this is a
debate that has been raging since the
inception of Christianity itself going
all the way back to the life of Jesus
and the times of Jesus so let's sit down
and sift through the information so that
we can now take a stepping stone
platform okay who was Jesus what did he
teach and preach which we have discussed
and now what does that mean to me you
know did he preach a finalized message
which is another thing that we discussed
that he did not preach a finalized
message he preached an intermediary
message from one messenger to the next
leading to something else which was part
of his final message that what I have to
say to you was not yet finished and that
was one of my purest things towards my
Christian counterparts was that look
Jesus said himself his message wasn't
done so we need to look and find where's
the end of the message since he didn't
finish it what finished it where did it
come and complete itself and this is
where we have to put the Islamic
perspective in just to show people that
Jesus was a stepping stone that all the
messengers of God starting with Noah
peace be upon him pointed forward to
something else and even Jesus himself
and then the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him very clearly stated that those
messengers all pointed forward to me so
so can you can you say that for those
people that I'm just you know trying to
have them identify with us that when you
really grasped as this extension of the
the message that all the messengers of
God brought brought and taught the
purpose of life worshiping one God doing
good deeds developing yourself to be
Noble having righteous character this is
how you can truly because those people
were out there at the nightclubs you
know chasing man and woman you know
fornicating and doing drugs they'll
never have true peace until they truly
understand the purpose of life and this
is like you said that stepping stone so
you can get through the confusion so you
can submit intellectually because this
is something that it doesn't take too
much mental gymnastics to make fit it
makes sense we're talking about is 1+1
ABC yes absolutely
you know this is very clear that you
know people who are there living that
that lifestyle that very fast-paced
lifestyle in the nightclubs in the
streets and all of these things we all
know that those people at the
of the road they always come to a point
to where they say that none of this
really satisfied me it was kind of a you
know a bandage for a while it made me
feel good for a period of time but then
you're always left with that down phase
again this is what leads to addictions
is that people have to continuously
fulfill that that that hold inside of
themselves but when people decide to
sober up whether it be from drugs or
alcohol or from that fast-paced
lifestyle they realize that I need
something more defined in my life and
this is what we're trying to offer them
that definition of life what is life
what does it mean and how can I adjust
myself to be more in line with the
purpose of why I'm here that's right
that's right and this way of life will
stimulate you intellectually it provides
all the scientific logical evidences and
we're going to continue talking about
this with my guests back on the Dean
show job
Joshua Evan sit tight don't go nowhere
right back death and the day of judgment
the mercy of Allah these are the things
that finally made me realize there is no
time to delay any more I want you to
take Marshall harder right there the
essence of spirituality is to become
more sincere to Allah spend whatever but
to play death itself it is very very
scary but it brings you back to if there
is a life which is everlasting and if
you and you have to make a conscious
decision of which a group of people do
you want to be believe I'm having over
the people of help
back here on the Dean show with Joshua
Evans we did the top 10 reasons why
Jesus peace be upon him is not God never
claimed to be God you can go to the Dean
show com to watch this show that we did
together an amazing amazing show that
really you know benefited so many people
now there were some angry people there
was a a minut few that we had discussed
that now they couldn't tackle this
intellectually and it stirred up so much
emotion that they'll try to flip it and
say you know what
you know Islam is violent Islam is about
terrorism Islam is just about oppression
of women and they start to throw sticks
and stones and did you get some of this
I absolutely did you know and that's
that kind of happens when people get
emotional but cannot you know retort
intellectually because the information
is so clear so you have to lash out with
some type of
oceans and we see that a lot of people
lash out by you know saying things
negative about the other person or their
way of life or whatever and it's very
sad but we did see that you know that
all you know they would try to change
the subject or the Islam is a violent
religion you know you're trying to call
to the religion of Islam its violent its
oppressive and teachings all these crazy
things so we did see that you know how
did you tackle this now because you'll
see a lot of Islamophobia now okay you
see people who want to get elected and
now also because a lot of the people now
they're they're ignorant they don't know
and and the people who are supposed to
have these degrees and they step up
instead of bringing people together and
really trying to work towards peace they
start to divide people because they have
an agenda and people now they end up
blindly following a lot of these
politicians other people at agenda who
are not working towards peace and they
start to create through this bigotry and
you know staring up people's emotions
and they start to separate us
we're human beings were brothers in
humanity so how would you for instance
one one film just came out it was called
unwelcome yes you know the Muslims
necked your Muslim next-door right so
did you watch this film I did what were
you what were your comments on it well
realistically you know a lot of things
that were put forward and welcomed is is
a way you know a portion of Americans do
feel about Islam and the world feels
about Islam but it's based on pure
ignorance which ignorant not being in
the negative connotation of ignorance
just means lack of knowledge you know
they just don't know and the best way to
deal with ignorance is to tell the truth
and to make the truth known if someone
is ignorant about a subject didn't the
best way to cure that ignorance is with
information so you know what I have
tried to do in my worldwide travels is
just clearly give the real information
out about Islam tell people what Islam
is really about so that they can kind of
sift through the misinformation so that
they can when they see the TV when they
see the media representation of Islam
they can look and say okay wait a minute
this is not what islam teaches what
they're saying and what islam teaches
are two completely different things this
is what we really want to do the same
way like they're trying to make dividing
lines you know you either with us or
you're with them so we're trying to make
the dividing lines but between what
Islam is and what Islam is not very
simple now we know that this is false
and you've heard this a lot why don't
they come out and why don't they condemn
acts such as 9/11 you know the underwear
bomber the pajama bomber the you know
the the g-string bomber I mean but we I
mean here at the Dean show I know I know
you have and and we've had scholars on
the show who have clearly condemned acts
like 9/11 pajama bomber g-string bomb
whatever kind of bomber shoe bomber you
invented Islam says clearly don't kill
women don't kill children don't kill the
old people is clear about that now
you'll still have people say you know I
know it's less llamas about okay
it's Lomb is about you know terrorizing
people oppressing women so how would you
I just stated that this is clearly
against the teachings of Islam and we've
had some of the if people can go through
our shows clearly we'll have people who
have condemned these acts how do you
when someone comes and says no no no no
you you got the beard now you know and
you're the guy that's those guys you
know that's the guys trying to kill us
they're coming with the Sharia the
boogeyman is coming you're trying to
take my freedom away what do you got to
say to him well really realistically we
just tell them the truth because rather
than you know talking about each and
every one of these acts Muslims always
having to come out and condemn this act
condemn that the easier thing is to like
I said tell people what Islam is really
about and what Islam is not about then
that puts a blanket you know statement
over all of these things so if anything
comes into this that's not that then
it's not Islam for instance we know that
Islam is a way of life that means
submitting oneself to your creator each
and every single day in obedience to him
in order to obtain peace in my life in
order to obtain peace in the next life
this is the meaning of Islam itself and
a Muslim only means someone who does
Islam someone who does Islam someone who
submits themselves to the creator in a
very obedient fashion in order to obtain
peace now to say that I'm gonna submit
myself to my creator in order to obtain
peace through violence and through
killing innocents and doing things which
God himself has forbidden is is is very
illogical even for me to say that is
illogical I have made statements that
take me out of the fold of Islam and all
of these things we see
coming out like you know you should be
afraid of the Sharia which we see being
very very much put forward in the media
you should be afraid of the Sharia law
and the Quran and all of these things
when we tell the world what these things
are really about then the information is
there for them to take that this is the
boundaries of Islam these and even in
the Quran it says very clearly that God
has laid out boundaries he's laid out
boundaries these are considered his
boundary points do not transgress beyond
them for if you do you will be a
rebellious sinner so we have to let
people know not only in from give this
information to Muslims who may be
unaware but tell non-muslims who may be
in a way these are the boundaries of
Islam if anything is outside of this
it's not its name and most of the things
they are being put forward that are
supposedly done by Muslims or supposedly
done in the name of a sin you will find
are outside of those boundaries so they
are not within the religion of Islam so
we don't really need to go on about
every single shoe bomber whatever bomber
this that and the other because we can
just say look we've given you a clear
description of what it's name isn't what
its name is not you can see very clearly
this is on the outside or you can see
this is on the inside so the information
can be read it available to the public a
statement that we've heard some people
such as glenn beck and a riley and all
these other people they say Muslims
killed us on 9/11 this is a blanket
statement and they'll say also and we
know a Muslim is simply one Jesus was a
Muslim Abraham Moses Noah John the
Baptist Isaac Ishmael they were all
Muslim someone says how is that because
they all submitted to the one God they
did Islam Islam means to submit to get
peace by submitting to that Creator who
created all that exists they'll say you
know what okay okay you know and and and
you'll hear this a lot so I'm gonna put
it on you right now because we're asking
those tough questions all Muslims
they're not terrorists but all
terrorists are Muslims how would you
answer that that's that's a very
unfortunate statement because it is very
contradictory to facts and this is the
real way to sift through this
information is let the you know as they
say put out the facts and let the cards
fall where they may
you know and and unfortunately this
ideology is is is very much tinted to
distract people from the real message of
Islam
to keep us continually on the defensive
you know so that the real message of
Islam does not get conveyed so the way
we can you know take care of both of
these issues is by telling the real
masses of Islam in order to dispel these
myths and misinformation to say that all
terrorists are Muslims is just very
plainly contradictory to factual
information even amongst you know recent
history and we look back to the before
9/11 the greatest terrorist act of our
century on American soil
was extracted upon America by a
non-muslim Timothy McVeigh and the
Oklahoma City bombing I don't remember
him ever confessing that he was a Muslim
and this was one of the greatest
terrorist acts come on on on US soil and
to say that 9/11 was a Muslim act it's
just very contrary to the information it
was an act of aggression and an act of
violence and an act of terrorism in
reality and and this is against the very
teachings of Islam so we put the facts
where they are out there that the
terrorism is not a monopoly of Islam and
even though we do have and we have to
put the information clearly that there
are a small percentage of the Muslim
population who may have some extreme
ideas and may have twisted Islam a
little bit and and/or a great extent you
know to use violence to to you know to
vent their frustrations and aggressions
but do it in a manner that is not
according to the religion of Islam then
we have to be clear about that too that
they have stepped outside of the
boundaries and but Islam does not hold a
monopoly of terrorism and extremism this
is not I'm gonna play this name this is
something that has played every single
major world religion throughout history
let's stop killing each other I mean
this is clear we know that it's wrong to
go over overseas and bomb innocent
people in another land and and and kill
them and this guy is eating a falafel
and next to you know you know he's over
there
here didn't hurt him some sheep and
actually no he goes back to his family's
whole village is killed you know guys
never never had a TV doesn't even know
what's going on in America didn't want
to hurt nobody he's just praying to the
one guy next to you know his innocent
child you know was just born and his
baby girl they're all dead
so you know these these emotions start
to stir up and people do things that
aren't according to Islam so let's stop
killing and sending innocent people to
kill
other innocent people this is wrong but
we also like you said we'll admit that
there are some people with some extreme
views but the main thing is I liked what
you said this is what Islam says it's
Lomb says don't kill innocent women
children old people it's not justified
yes that's clear it's very clear
yeah there's no ambiguity about this
that's that's amazing and I'm sure the
light ball is going on and you're
learning so much you're getting to
benefit we'll be right back with more
hearing today so sit tight we'll find
that good peer out remind in your heart
of hatred and preconceived notions
racism and nationalism because you
cannot have anything inside of you
that's like that against people and
still be successful back here on the D
show with Joshua Evans and if you can go
to the D show calm we covered the top 10
reasons why Jesus peace be upon him has
not God never claimed to be God and some
people will get upset and they start you
know throwing sticks and stones want to
break your bones and and and and now
we're trying to intellectually we're
trying to explain what Islam is and you
clearly clearly again Islam is not about
terrorizing people terrifying oppressing
tyranny absolutely now this is the
anticipation it is it all of these
things are the complete complete
antithesis of the teachings of Islam
completely out of the scope I just I
want to hear you say it can you does any
Muslim have a right now okay because we
love our brothers in humanity and we
love our brothers in faith so those my
newphew that might have some extreme
views all right obviously you have a
right to defend yourself someone comes
put a gun to your head you know you hit
them with the left you don't let them
take your wallet you know you don't run
towards fighting you try to defuse a
situation but someone comes in your home
and try to stick you up in your family
have a right to defend yourself does a
Muslim one who has constantly submitted
to the one guy just like Jesus Abraham
knowing all of them that's what a Muslim
is does he have a right to put a bomb in
his shoe and his underwear behind
neck in his ear and you know try to go
and blow up innocent people in a
pizzeria in a game shop in a you know
Starbucks does he is this condone or
condemned by Islam absolutely condoned
and condemned ad that person would be
become a criminal condone or condemn I
know the words are slippery is it is it
justified or not it is absolutely not
condoned and it is clearly condemned
condemned that means it's not justified
not justified in Islam for someone to do
this they become a criminal according to
not only you know a secular law but the
religious law of Islam condemns them as
a criminal and they would be punished if
they didn't punish themselves by blowing
themselves up then they're gonna be in
Hellfire forever but if not and they
were caught in an Islamic system they
would be punished as a criminal now
again you got another person who is
clearly coming down speaking against
this so people such as some politicians
who say why don't the influential people
the Deen show here is viewed all across
the globe and it's one of the most
watched talk shows and we have some of
the most known speakers out there and
this is just another speaker another
person who is well known throughout the
Muslim world who's speaking out against
this so let's go onto the next we're
almost wrapping up at Sharia you
mentioned Sharia earlier and isn't
Sharia also I like how you eloquently
put it one these things are explained
you know the walls come down didn't
Jesus teach Sharia didn't Moses teach
Sharia define what Sharia is and when I
say look the ten commands this was
Sharia what do I mean
Sharia is an Arabic word that basically
means the way a way in an Arabic
terminology it defines a way that leads
to water and Islamic lyric that is a way
or a method or a methodology that leads
to God's pleasure so what is a system of
laws that God has given us to do Islam
to be a Muslim and it gives us a path
and a way to do that because it's a
logic for God to put us on this earth
say I want you to obey me this and that
the other but not yet show us the way to
get there you know it's like somebody
telling you to go somewhere but you can
get there however you want that's just a
logical I know I need a destination
India
I need the the roadmap so their Sharia
is the roadmap Moses was given the
Sharia and the roadmap in the Ten
Commandments Jesus himself was a
proponent of following the law which we
spoke about in our true gospel of Jesus
Christ video here on the Dean show that
he taught to obey the commandments of
God and to follow the law of God which
means the Sharia in Islam it's the same
thing we're following the laws and the
regulations sent down by the Creator
Almighty to do his worship and and this
is well defined in Islam to say that it
is anything other than this simplistic
lifestyle to please the Creator is just
a a misconstrue 'ti of information and
it's just you know blanketing over the
facts with with with statements that are
not true I can clearly say because now
we're running out of time
now we're gonna lay it out and people
could judge for themselves I know and I
can just passionately say if you have a
Muslim living next to you you can count
on him sometimes taking your trash out
you can count on him not using profanity
you can count on him not trying to steal
your wife you can count on him not
stealing your wallet trying to rob your
house you won't see him on the FBI's or
the top ten most wanted you can rest
assured that you will have peace from
this neighbor if he's abiding by Islam
he's a good noble character what do you
guys say about this absolutely for
someone who is living as a Muslim and
they are practicing Muslim which are the
ones people are going to most readily
recognize then these are people that you
would not ever have to worry about fear
about you know because if they are
practicing Muslim they are taught to be
good to their neighbor they are taught
to be good to their parents to humanity
to help in society to be socially
conscious all of these things are within
the boundaries and the teachings of
Islam the Quran the Sharia and the
teachings of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him that we are to deal with
humanity and one very beautiful
statement of the Prophet peace be upon
him was that you do not truly believe
until you love for your brother in
humanity what you love for yourself so
we have to deal with humanity as we
would want to be treated and this is of
course the Golden Rule talk about Jesus
peace be upon him himself as reporting
the New Testament all of these teachings
are the same we're not bringing anything
new we're just trying to revive this old
ancient teaching from God from the very
beginning of time into
and that we want to please him and we
want to have a good right just society
that's what Islam offers and seeks to
bring to the world now we're just about
out of time
Islam lay it out what is Islam what does
it mean what is it calling to talk to us
Aslam is very simple it's named as an
Arabic word that means many things but
if we wanted to break it down
simplistically out of all of the
meanings in words Islam means submission
serenity sincerity obedience and peace
that basically means Islam that I submit
myself to God I do what he wants me to
do each and every single day sincerely
for him in obedience to him surrendering
to him alone so that I can have peace in
this life and I can have peace in the
next life and if I seek to do that every
day then I would be known as a Muslim
one who does Islam one who submits this
is very simple this is all of the
prophets and messengers of God people
who submitted even as Jesus peace be
upon him said that whatever is your
wheel gun the Creator that I will do
that is a Muslim whatever is God's will
that's what we want to do we started
with peace we end with peace peace be
unto you thank you he's coming back
again inshallah we look forward to
having you in shock again God willing on
the disha my pleasure the God Almighty
the creator Allah rewards you I mean and
that was exciting for me I know it was
exciting for you we clearly got to
define what Islam is and Jesus did Islam
and we're not the Antichrist and we love
Jesus and we love peace but to get peace
within yourself you got to turn to the
owner of peace the one who created you
not to a man to a woman but to the
creator of man and woman the creator of
this whole universe and everything in it
and he doesn't call us to want to pull
up our neighbors and to kill this person
and that person no he calls us to that
which is good and it's not good to kill
innocent people it's not good to go out
and create mischief in the land Islam
calls us to submit to the one God to do
righteous good deeds and to yearn for
paradise but how can you have paradise
if you're not obeying God so obey God do
the wonderful beautiful things that he
wants you to do have good manners good
noble character develop yourself to be
the best human being
that you can be and continue to tune in
here to the Dean show until next time
peace be unto you